herzlich willkommen in meine taten welt
heute gibt's ein kleines weihnachtliches
rezept und zwar ist ein sehr schnelles
rezept ich habe es selbst noch nicht
ausprobiert ich werde heute sind
röckchen machen und hab das rezept aus
diesem land kinos heft vom letzten jahr
ist es allerdings und starrsinn medizin
troll einfach aufgefallen weil ich aus
und so sein wie zink li power bin und
weil es einfach ein rezept ist das
ziemlich schnell geht und weil ich weiß
dass ihr solche rezepte möglich dachte
ich beginne ich mal mit so einem
einfachen rezept ich werde dieses rezept
jetzt gleich vorbereiten
hier steht drin dass man den teig der
nacht ruhen lassen muss
ich frage mich dann oftmals wieso man
das machen muss und deswegen werde ich
jetzt für euch testen einmal den teig
direkt zu verarbeiten und einmal ebene
nacht stehen zu lassen und am nächsten
tag zu verarbeiten und dann werde ich
mich einfach zeigen was der unterschied
ist und ob sie es eben lohnt den teig
der nacht stehen zu lassen oder eben
nicht
aber damit wir jetzt anfangen können
seitlich einmal die zutaten und zeigt
euch daran wie es weitergeht
ihr braucht sechs eiweiß 120 gramm
butter des schönen zimmer warm 200 gramm
puderzucker 150 gramm mehl 1 2 teelöffel
zimt und man lewis dass ich sind gern
mag nehme ich natürlich zwei teelöffel
ihr braucht eine prise salz für das
eiweiß und etwa einen esslöffel
schlagsahne
zuerst wird jetzt das eiweiß steif
geschlagen und das mache ich jetzt in
der kitchen aid wer eine art wird mehr
bestätigen können dass es da wirklich
super schnell geht und da gebe ich jetzt
noch die presales mit dazu die bewegt
nämlich dass die eiweiß struktur
zerstört und somit das eiweiß schnell
dazu schnell geschlagen wird
und findet es dann weiter gebt ihr etwas
zwei bis drei esslöffel vom puderzucker
mit dazu und lasst es weiter schönen
steif schlagen und dann könnt ihr das
eiweiß zur seite stellen jetzt wird die
butter mit dem puderzucker schön cremig
gerührt und das mache ich hier mit
diesem flach hörer
und hier habe ich jetzt schon dass
medien sind verrührt das kommt oder auch
noch mit rein und dann auch gleich ein
esslöffel sahne
das wird jetzt einmal kurz unter gerührt
und wenn ihr merkt dass die sahne bei
euch nicht reicht gibt einfach nur einen
kleinen schluck mit dazu und jetzt hebt
ihr einfach nach und nach etwas eis
schnee unter diesen tag
und so sieht dann der fertige teig aus
wie ich freund schon gesagt habe werde
ich den teig jetzt zum teil schon
verwerten und schon die röllchen daraus
packungen und den anderen teil werde ich
dann in den kühlschrank geben und danach
dem kühlschrank lassen und morgen früh
daneben backen
ich zeige ich es einfach wie ich das
mache und zeit mich dann wie die
röllchen aufgerollt werden
ich nehme mir dann einen esslöffel teig
geben auch mein buckles und verstreicht
ohne moral geht mit dem teig richtig gut
das verstreichen geht übrigens mit
dieser mini winkel palette viel besser
da kann man es richtig schön gleichmäßig
verstreichen
einfach hier drüber ziehen so sieht das
ganze ist bei mir aus und ihr solltet
auch nicht mehr als vier dollar auf ein
backblech setzen weil sie noch etwas zu
laufen und so werden sie jetzt vier bis
fünf minuten bei 220 grad ober und
unterhitze gebacken und danach zeige ich
euch wie es weitergeht so sehen die zehn
platten jetzt auswählen so auslaufen
kommen dunkler dürfen sie auch nicht
werden
und ich nehme mir jetzt hier einfach so
diese kleinen käse und schauen wörtchen
und rollt es schnell drauf ein
ich lass dir auch absichtlich auf dem
blech damit jetzt nicht kalt werden und
bin ich zusammen brechen müsste jetzt
ganz fix machen
denn sobald die kalt werden werden sie
brüchig
weil sie dann knusprig werden und das
wollen wir ja wir wollen der knusprige
hähnchen so lasse ich jetzt hier
erhalten und kann hier auf meinen blake
schon mal die nächste portion machen den
restlichen teig werde ich jetzt aber
erstmal in den kühlschrank stellen um
das wie gesagt zu testen wie die
röllchen dann sind wenn ich sie eine
nacht im kühlschrank habe dazu gebe ich
sehr ein gebe ich den tag einfach in
diese to the box macht den deckel drauf
und gibt es für eine nacht in den
kühlschrank
die röllchen würde ich dann auch relativ
schnell wieder von diesen einbrüchen
befreien und sie dann komplett auskühlen
lassen also die lage jetzt hier so etwa
fünf minuten sind noch etwa hand war
und da stecke ich einfach den finger
rein und kann
solchen raus drehen und lass dir eben
ganz gut auskühlen eine nacht ist jetzt
vorbei und ich habe jetzt den teig aus
dem kühlschrank genommen der erste
unterschiedlicher stellen kann ist das
datei geht's einfach sein fest ist weil
die butter in dem teil geht es natürlich
wieder kalt geworden ist und kalte
butter ist eben hat ich würde mal
behaupten dass sich dann das
verstreichen eben etwas als schwieriger
erweist als er mit dem frischen teig
aber wir schauen jetzt einfach mal
gemeinsam wie es klappt und wie das eben
am besten funktioniert am nächsten
morgen zieht der teig so aus und ich
versuche das jetzt einfach mal dass ich
wüsste jetzt nicht wieso ich sitz besser
gehen sollte geht eher schlecht ich
würde sagen dass man den teig nicht über
nacht in den kühlschrank stellen muss
sondern dass man einfach den frischen
teig direkt auf die backbleche verteilen
kann und verstreichen kann weil es
einfach viel einfacher geht und ihr eben
dadurch auch die zeit sport diese
uhrzeit im kühlschrank und jetzt müssen
die leuchten einfach alle komplett
auskühlen und wenn sie dann abgekühlt
sind sind so richtig schön knusprig und
schmecken auch richtig schön zickig und
ich kann mir ganz gut vorstellen dass
man da auch andere aromen mit dazu geben
kann wenn zum beispiel jemand etwas
orangenschale mit reinen gibt dann
verleiht dem ganzen noch mal so ein
frischeres aruba man kann ja auch andere
gewürze mit rein geben damit das ganze
noch etwas weihnachtlicher und
winterlicher wird ich sage jetzt einfach
mal meine fertigen röckchen und zeige
ich auch wie viele ich da raus aus
diesem einen tag gewonnen habe und so
sehen dann am ende die ganze welt
reichen aus meine reichen bin jetzt
fertig und zu sehen selbst aus sind es
so etwa 30 stück geworden ein paar sehen
wir auch etwas zusammen gebracht weil
ich so auf ein blech vergessen habe und
sie nicht gleich eingeräumt habe also
dann ist er wirklich drauf aufpassen
dass er sie direkt nach dem backen
sofort wenn sie noch ganz heiß sind eine
rolle auch wenn ihr euch dabei die
finger verbrennt aber es
lohnt sich auf jeden fall also diesen
auch richtig schön knusprig wie gesagt
könnt ihr doch andere aromen hinzufügen
oder die reichen zum beispiel auch nicht
irgendwas gefühlt aber ich finde einfach
lecker sehr gut und ich hoffe dass euch
dieses rezept gefällt das rezept ist er
einfach aber etwas zeitaufwendig sound
einfach bis man diese teigmasse immer
ein bisschen verstrichen hat und muss
eben kammern und am herd stehen und
sofort nach 34 minuten die röhrchen aus
dem backofen holen
das rezept gibt es wie immer zum
nachlesen auf meinem blog auf www.ms
torten welt.de und dann wünsche ich euch
noch einen schönen tag und bis bald